[AUDIO LOGO]
So Happy Thursday, everybody.
Welcome to the Data
Science Hangout.
Hope everybody is
having a great week.
I'm Rachael, if we
haven't met yet.
Let us know if it's
your first time joining.
Do you want to say
hello in the chat
so we can all welcome
you in together?
This is an open space to chat
about data science leadership,
questions you're
facing, and getting
to hear about what's going
on in the world of data
across different industries.
And so every week, we feature
a different data science leader
as my co-host to help us lead
the discussion and answer
questions from you all.
Together, we're all
dedicated to making
this a welcoming
environment for everybody.
And I love to hear from
everyone, no matter
your level of experience
or area of work.
It is totally OK just to
listen in if you want.
There's always three ways
that you can ask questions,
though, and also provide
your own perspective
on certain topics.
So you can always jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put
a little star next to it
if you want me to
read it if you're
in a coffee shop or something.
And then we also
have a Slido link
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
And Hannah will share
that in the chat
here in just a second again.
We do share the
recordings of each session
so they'll be up on the Posit
YouTube as well as the Data
Science Hangout site.
But with all of that,
thank you so much,
Regis, for joining us
as our co-host today.
Regis James is a senior manager
of biopharmaceutical data
science at Regeneron
Pharmaceuticals.
And Regis, I'd love to have
you introduce yourself, then
maybe start off by sharing
a little bit about your role
and something you like to
do outside of work too.
Sure.
Thanks for having me.
Let's see, a little
bit about my role
and what I like to do outside.
So I've been on the
side of the company
that I'm on right now
for almost nine months.
But before that-- and I'll
kind of clarify what I mean
by that--
I came to Regeneron right
out of my PhD in 2016.
And I was on the R&amp;D side.
And I did a lot
of collaborations
with biologists who were
generating tons of data,
but it was kind of
challenging to make decisions
based on that data.
So what I did a lot
was distill things down
to their fundamentals to
simplify the process of going
from stuck to unstuck.
And in June of last
year, I moved over
to be a bit closer to the
patients, which has always
been my passion ever since
before I went to undergrad
for bioengineering.
But I wanted to be closer
to the clinical trial side,
so that's where I am now.
And I'm working to help
optimize clinical trials
using AI and ML.
But there are a lot
of different parts
of the side of the company
that I've moved to,
which is called global
development, that are not just
clinical trials.
There are a whole
bunch of other things.
And we are in the
process of figuring out
how to establish some of
these collaborations with them
as well.
I also have since the time
that I was on the R&amp;D side
have been maintaining a
community of data scientists
that are around
the entire company,
and since Regeneron is global.
It's actually a
global organization.
And the reason why this
organization formed
was because when I came
right out of my PhD,
the ecosystem that I
used was R and RStudio--
now Posit's environment
of RStudio IDE and Shiny
Server Pro, which has now been
evolved into RStudio Connect.
So I needed to
get that set up so
that I could do the same
level of collaborations
with non computational
people that I
did during my grad school
work but at Regeneron.
So when I set that up,
other people heard about it.
And they're like, oh, my
gosh, this is amazing.
Can we please do this?
So then I started
letting people on, but--
I don't want to say
with great power
comes great responsibility,
but with great open source
access comes great
responsibility to support
an ongoing community of people.
So that ended up happening.
And what people were doing
was building Shiny apps
and a whole bunch of different
other types of analytics
that they were sharing with
noncomputational colleagues.
And so I started hosting these
showcases that would show--
I hadn't mentioned this
part to you, Rachael--
but that would show what
people had been building.
And then they would kind
show it to a range of people
around the company,
which was kind of-- it
was feeding as a
positive feedback loop
because people
started understanding,
as my current boss calls,
it the art of possible.
So then they were like,
wait, that's why--
does that mean we can do this?
And can we do that?
Can we do that?
So then it kind of
started growing.
So then I was only
working in the R side
and supporting that community.
But then similarly, I can't
remember which one happened
first, but it was very close in
time to when RStudio was like,
there's other people in the
world who use data science.
I mean, the IDE Workbench
always supported a broad range
of languages.
But to make it more
formally cross-language,
that happened
around the same time
that I moved the group
from just R people to R
and other programming
languages that
exist to enable data science.
So that's the group that I
convene every other Friday.
And yeah, we're
having one tomorrow.
It's internal, of course.
But we're-- so we talk about the
problems that data scientists
face and how we address them.
And then it kind of often,
especially this year, it's
been triggering spin off
meetings of other people
who have common problems and
they exist across the company.
So it's been going pretty well.
In my free time, I mean, I
am a lover of sci-fi things.
So I have for a couple of years
been working on a data science
novel series that
takes all of the geeky,
nerdy, awesome things like
cryptocurrency and CRISPR
and a whole bunch
of different things
and integrates them into
what I think is going
to be an interesting story.
And I'm planning
on releasing that
at some point in the future.
So that's what I
do in my free time.
And I've been able
to influence or I've
been able to attract my
wife to also contribute.
And she's also a
scientist, so sometimes we
have these brainstorming
sessions about different plot
points that could happen
and making them realistic,
but also having a bunch
of action in there too.
So that's the thing
I do in my free time
with my favorite person.
I love it.
It sounds like you
have a lot of people
who want to buy that in
the chat here right now.
So when that's out,
we'll have to put it
on the list of
recommendations too,
all the books Livy's
been collecting.
But I'm so excited that you
started off with community
because that's something that
I was going to ask you about
as well, because I was
leading a community building
workshop at ANT Pharma.
And during that
workshop, I personally
learned so much from
you, Regis, and just
wanted to be able to share
that with everybody here too.
But you just said
that a lot of people
start having these spinoff
meetings from the Friday
sessions, which is amazing.
And I was just wondering, how
do you help facilitate that
within the community?
So they haven't always been--
like the spinoffs have kind
of started a little bit more
recently.
Sometimes there have been
a thing here or there.
I haven't, to be honest--
and everything's a
work in progress.
The community is about
helping each other figure out
how to figure stuff out.
So in the most recent
spinoff, I wasn't exactly sure
where my role was.
They were like, thank you,
Regis, we are together.
We're meeting each other
because of the organization
that you created.
And I was like, yes, cool.
But I'm still trying to
figure out exactly what it is.
And I mean, I don't
think I should
be in charge of everything.
It's good for things
to happen organically,
but be triggered by existing
problems that people have.
The thing that happened recently
with our-- because of course
I can't go into detail
about what it was,
but I can speak in general but
yet specific for this community
in data science terms.
It was about natural
language processing
in different contexts
to identify things
that we need to act on.
And there are three
different parts
of the company that
have the same problem.
And we would not have come
together without that.
So people were asking questions.
What I typically do though
when I prep the speaker--
so it's every other Friday.
And before last year, I was
setting a meeting-- actually,
I was doing it
even more lightly.
I was just messaging
them on Microsoft Teams
to say, hey, are you
ready, do you have X, Y, Z?
So that we can share
it with the community.
But as things have
gotten more complicated
and people schedules
have gotten crazier,
now, I have my schedule
set out for the whole year
basically until the end
of 2023 every other Friday
except for holidays.
So now what I've done is--
I have the page open right
here on my other screen--
I have a column of red,
green, and yellow icons
indicating whether or
not the scheduled date is
locked down or not.
So whenever I have it locked
down when the person agrees,
then I schedule the
two weeks before.
So not the Monday
of the gathering,
but the Monday before, I meet
with them to make sure we
have everything
together so that it's
really easy for the people who
are in attendance to know what
the walkaway scenario,
what the takeaway point is
so they can apply
it to their own work
as quickly as possible.
So I do a lot of honing there.
And I think it's been paying
off because in the meetings,
people have been really engaged
and have been asking questions
during the meetings
because I've been
able to whittle it down the
speaker that I have tomorrow.
I said, I apologize.
I don't mean to ask
you to ruin your story,
but it may be helpful
if you'd say the end
part at the beginning.
And he's was like, no,
no, no, please, please,
I do want to ruin it.
So I think that would--
But having them basically
ruin their stories
and saying the end at the
beginning is what gets--
I think it helps
people get engaged.
So there were
different departments
that got engaged
because of the way
I was able to flip
the narrative and say
the ending from the beginning.
And so because of
that part, I think,
people who are able to
just jump in and identify
things that were needed.
And so kind of-- it's
a long winded way
of saying that I was sort
of sitting and listening
to the sub-group from
the community talk.
I was involved in one
of the projects that
were discussed in the spinoff.
But yeah, it was more just
kind of sitting and listening
and figuring out, oh,
this is a new thing.
Where do I sit?
If anyone has recommendations
on how I could probably
engage in that, I'm all ears.
That's great.
Pulling that up to the
front so that people
know why they want to pay
attention to it too is--
I was trying to grab the link,
but I remember [INAUDIBLE]
at Posit I gave a talk a few
years ago about letting them
eat cake first when
teaching students
and showing them the
pretty application
first that they might make.
Yu, I see you have
your hand raised.
You want to jump in?
YU CAO: Sure.
Hi, Regis.
First, this is Yu Cao.
I'm a data science professional
from a finance company,
and I have a technical question.
You just mention that
you are doing LP model.
So could you share
some details of this
because we are doing
something similar?
So for your LP model,
what's your raw material?
Is this conversation over
the phone or some transcript?
What is it?
What is that?
I cannot go into detail about
it because it's proprietary
company information, at
least what the data is.
But I can say at a higher
level that one of the--
so one of the three
chunks of the company that
was represented and
multiple people from each
of those-- well, one
chunk had only one person.
But another chunk had
two or three people,
and another chunk had
four or five people
all together in their meeting.
And so one of the
chunks of the company
was getting their data off of
machines and another is from,
we'll say processes that happen.
And then yet another
is from the literature
and data sets that
exist from data that's
been collected basically.
But yeah, are you getting at--
I'm inferring that maybe you're
thinking that you can't even
start this type of work
unless you have data together
in the first place.
Is that what you're thinking?
YU CAO: Yes.
We are currently trying to use
call transcripts for the LP
model.
It's a little bit
challenging because
of quality of these transcripts
that is not very good.
So I'm wondering what type of
materials do you start with.
Well, but-- right.
So yeah, I can't get into
the specifics of that,
but I'm just wondering
if you've thought about--
so you said call
transcripts, but I'm just
wondering how are you
generating the transcripts.
And I'm hoping it's not
human beings writing it.
YU CAO: No, [INAUDIBLE] system.
Yeah.
So I'm just wondering if
you've been able to consider
upgrading the tech--
the speech-to-text
technology that you're using.
Perhaps that could help increase
the quality because I mean,
it's that technology is
evolving at an alarming rate.
Well, it would be
alarming if it weren't
working for us as
a human species
because that's what
Google is using.
I don't know if you're
using Google to extract text
from the speech.
But there's a variety
of technologies
that are doing that.
Can you comment on
that or is that also
proprietary on your side?
YU CAO: Probably I cannot
share details either.
But anyway, thank you very
much for your suggestion.
And if needed, we
can't talk later.
Yeah.
Cool.
So we just had a
great conversation
about the thing that
you do and the thing
I do that [INAUDIBLE] thinks.
Cool.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: All the things.
YU CAO: Thank you.
All the things.
YU CAO: Thank you, Rachael.
Yeah.
I saw an anonymous
question that
said, is it OK to
post LinkedIn URL
or mention that you're
looking for data positions.
And absolutely, feel free to
put anything into the chat
that you want.
And if people are hiring
for certain positions,
if you want to share
those job roles there,
feel free to share that to.
Not spammy at all.
An anonymous question
for you, Regis,
was question from all
clinical pharma management.
Do you have a validated
server to run R?
And can it replace a
SaaS validated server?
I will speak in hypotheticals.
Great question.
Validated servers are
necessary, they should exist,
and setting them
up is complicated.
That's the end.
Another question was--
I think this is from Bill in
the chat who was commenting
on the novel approach.
Have you published parts
of it online anywhere
and submitted it
to The New Yorker?
Of what?
YU CAO: Your novel
that you're working on.
The novel.
No, not yet.
Because here's
the thing that's--
I love it, but also,
it slows things down.
The world, all
these smart people
that are on the call and
a bunch of other people
keep coming up with other
technologies that make
for great narrative fodder.
So I keep getting tempted
to, oh, well, that
would be a great plot point.
This would be a
great plot point too.
There's a YouTube
account, I think,
where a guy knows how to
act like Keanu Reeves.
And so they deep fake his face.
And just think about all
of the potential espionage
and whatever that can occur.
So it's data science-driven
interesting plot points.
Marlene, I see you
have your hand raised.
You want to jump in?
Yeah.
I think the answer to
your problem, Regis.
Just by the way, hi,
and it's been pretty fun
listening to you chat.
I think the answer
is instead of a book
because the lead time is so
long to get that published is
a comic, right?
Something that's
quicker to spin out,
and it's a little
more time-sensitive
with what's coming out.
Because my fear is,
you get done publishing
and it's usually a year
or two down the line,
and almost some of
the conversation
is obsolete because so many--
especially this
particular industry,
everything rolls out fast.
Yep.
Absolutely.
A graphic novel or
comic would be really rad,
so food for thought.
That's a really great point.
Regis, something I was
wondering with the events
you have every other
week, what is something
that you found that people are
really interested in learning
more about?
Or to be able to
suggest topics too?
So I have A-- i built a Shiny
app for polling people so that
I could look at the distribution
of interest cross-sectional
or integrated cross section
with the department distribution
across our company.
And yeah, NLP and
machine learning
are at the top of
people's interest.
So that is without going
into specific detail
because if I comment on
what people are super, super
interested in, I don't
want to make any--
I'm not making any
public statement
about any what my
company is working on.
But I mean, machine learning
is what everyone is just
salivating over.
So how do you go about
finding people to actually speak
on those topics?
Like you're actively reaching
out to people, do you think?
Yeah.
So one of the things
I do, and I hope
this doesn't make anyone
who's in the group who
may be in attendance
here not do this,
but so I've got-- what I
do is I maintain-- everyone
is special in case anyone
watches this video.
Everyone's special.
But in order to
achieve scalability,
I do have to standardize
things a bit.
So I have on--
because we use Confluence.
So on the wiki that I've
made, I have a lockdown page
where I have some
standardized messages
that I send out to people at
different phases of things.
And I do customize
and I read what
people say about
themselves and I'm like,
OK, this could be useful here,
that could be useful there.
So one of the things
that I do is--
I kind of have this
whole ingestion pipeline
that I maintain to identify
new members of the community,
and then of those members, who
can help the community learn
more about what the blockers are
to the current responsibilities
they have for their job.
So I mean, all companies
have a directory
where you can learn about
who exists at the company.
You can see people's
job titles and stuff.
So one of the
things that I do is
I can look into
the directory and I
can look for like data or
data science or whatever.
And then the people that
come out in the results
like when I search
for those terms,
I look to see if they're already
in my Microsoft Teams group.
And because I'm
thinking that they
could be potential
new people who
could benefit from
being in the community,
they might be able to do
their job better and also
help other people do their
job better if they can connect
to others who have similar needs
or can offer similar things.
So I look in the
company directory,
and then-- and I do it
on a semi-regular basis,
so I can really help to
onboard people who have just
joined the company or maybe
moved into a data science type
role.
So then I reach out
to these people,
and I use my standardized
thing like, hey,
I just want you to
know this group exists.
And I only send one email.
I don't spam people.
And I say like, hey, this
community was built just
for people like you.
This is what we do.
Here's a link to the wiki that
has the lengths of all the
recorded-- because we have
a growing library of all
the conversations just like
the Data Science Hangouts
that you have here.
So I send that link out to them.
And I say, hey,
this is something
that may be of use to you.
Let me know if you're
interested in it.
I can add you.
And look at all
the conversations
we've already had.
You be able to already
do something with it
yourself already.
So then-- of the subset.
Because it's not 100%.
Sometimes it's like
20% that respond.
And they say, yes,
this is amazing.
Thank you for letting me know.
I just came to the company.
I didn't even know if
there was a community.
And I'm also doing it
from my own perspective
of when I joined.
It was hard to see who
else may be able to speak
the same language about.
And not the language where
when you talk to someone,
their eyes glaze over.
It's not for the
non-computational.
It's for the
computational people.
So when they respond
and then they say,
yes, they're interested,
then I add them to the group.
But I have another thing
in my wiki for myself
in my lockdown page that is
the intro, the welcome words.
So I add them to
the Teams group.
Then I add them to the Active
Directory group, the Listserv.
And then I also
forward the invitation
to the ongoing gatherings
so every other Friday.
And in the invitation text I
paste in, welcome to the group.
Please introduce yourself
in the introduction section.
And I include a link, which I
use a tiny URL for because I
was using the full
URL from Confluence
and it was chopping things off.
But now that I use a tiny
URL, when they click it,
it takes them directly into not
just the Team for the group,
but the channel
of introductions.
So since I switched
over, I've gotten a lot
higher percentage of people who
have been added to the group
to start introducing themselves
and say what they work on.
So then I could see what
people are working on,
and then I integrate that
with my understanding of what
the output is, what
people have voted on
that they need help with
from the Shiny app that's
the poll for what people
are interested in.
And that's an open ended
thing too, by the way.
It's not that's
fixed set of things.
In Shiny, you can configure
it so that you can actually
add things in.
And that's got a MySQL back end.
So whatever people pick
from the dropdown menu,
it stores everything
in the back end
and then since I'm
using a global object--
I'm all over the
place, I apologize.
But since I'm using
a global object,
whenever anyone
updates something,
it automatically updates
the global object
and that propagates it down.
So it updates everybody's plot
regardless of what computer
you're looking at.
But I use that, and
then I integrate it
with what people say
in their introduction
and then I reach out
to them and say, hey,
would you be
interested in being one
of the guess for
an upcoming thing?
And then I send them the link.
And they can see
there's no pressure
because I'm a year out.
I've got someone
every other week.
So it's like, hey, would
this be something--
and then I kind of
just am gently having
a conversation over time.
And then sometimes,
people drop out.
And then I reach out to
those people and say, hey,
would you be able to switch?
So I have all of this
in my head all the time.
But I feel like if I--
This is my normal state.
I think less than
this, I would start--
I think I'm probably one of
those puppies who you probably
shouldn't leave at home with
nothing to do because they'll
just be like--
so yeah, this is great.
That's how I do it.
I love to see how excited
you get about this too.
I mean, I want to plus a million
to what Jared said in the chat.
I'm trying to scroll up
but Jared said, oh, my God,
you need to teach a class for
organizations for onboarding.
But I'm curious, where did
you learn all of this about
community building?
And how can we all
learn this from that?
I don't think I'm going
to have a satisfying answer.
I don't want to say
the answer in my head
because it's super
not satisfying.
OK.
So it just comes naturally.
It's not fair, but
it comes naturally.
One of my favorite places
to be is an airport,
not because of the lines,
but because for me, because--
Let me back up.
What I try to do
for my-- and it does
feed into all of this
stuff because I'm
trying to enable the things
that I'm trying to make possible
through my group.
So the purpose of the
group that I've created
is to help people
build their own careers
and also help the company help
patients with data science
more effectively.
But you can learn
from other people
about how you can build your
own career if you see how they
built their careers, sometimes.
You may be able to plug
and play different things,
mix and match.
And also hearing how
other people have
done the data science
implementation
in their own
respective projects,
you may be able to also mix
and match as well, kind of
like this series.
But naturally, the way
I see the world though
is like a combination
of The Matrix and Tron
in that in The Matrix,
you see like all the guys
that were looking at
the coding in the ship
and they could
see how everything
was like connected and
running and causality and all
of that stuff.
And in Tron, the way the
light cycles go around
and you kind of
see the story path.
I mean I'm thinking in-- they're
called world lines from my
studying from the novel.
It's an object four-dimensional
path in space time.
But that's how I
see everyone though.
Every single person that I just
walked around in the world,
it's like they have a Tron
light cycle path behind them.
And so I want to understand
about their light cycle path,
their world line because I
just think it's interesting.
Everyone has a different path.
I just think it's
interesting to know.
But also, it can
help other people.
So then I try to think
about how people--
because I'm fusing that with
the data-driven decision making
that I try to make it
possible for other people
to learn about.
And in order for people
to make decisions,
they need the right
information that
can help increase
their confidence
beyond the threshold of stuck.
So my brain is kind of always
running in the background,
how do I reduce the activation
energy so that people
can make decisions to get
engaged with the organization.
And also what frustrated
me in the past?
Why did I get frustrated
when I was at a meeting
and I was like, I
don't care about this?
This is not relevant to my life.
So we have over 300
people in the group,
but we don't always
have 300 people show up.
We have like 50 to 60,
sometimes a little bit more.
And that's because
part of the process
that I do because
I'm always thinking
about data driven decision
making but from a mushy side.
Because actually, my father--
both of my parents are
guidance counselors.
But my father is more the
emotional lifestyle kind
for students.
And my mother is more like the
hardcore organizational career
stuff.
So that's the example
I saw my whole life.
So because of that, I'm just
naturally doing both things.
So every single thing that I do
is geared towards emotionally
and logistically decreasing
the burden that people
face when they're
trying to decide,
should I do this or not?
And so my brain, things
pop into my head.
I just absorbed things from TV
shows, books, wherever I am,
I hear other people.
And I'm like, oh, I could plug
this in, I could plug that in.
My brain is like
a permanent graph
database where I just propagate
everything at all times.
My wife isn't the biggest
fan of not having separation
of concerns in my brain but--
Thank you for that
visualization too.
And honestly, it's
actually kind of validating
for me to hear that other
people's brains work
like that too.
Awesome.
But Mike, I see you had
asked a question in the chat
a bit earlier.
You want to jump in?
Thanks.
Regis, I'm loving what
you're saying here.
It's amazing stuff.
When you were talking--
and apologies, I
jumped in a bit late.
I may have missed this.
But when you're collating
all of that organizational
information, are you
building a knowledge graph?
What do you mean by
collating that organizational
information?
Well, were talking about in
the onboarding process being
able to identify all
the different people
within an organization, right?
That would be a good idea
to store that information
in a knowledge graph.
I am identifying
candidates for inclusion
on the basis of what their
job title is, which is already
something that exists.
But I think it
would be a good idea
to get a bit more information on
what their skill sets actually
are.
And of course, that
changes over time as well.
But at least from
a given timestamp,
what is their set of skills?
That's a need that I'm
pretty sure existed
a lot of different
institutions, and I've
heard it two different points
at least in the company
that it would be
great if there were
some sort of searchable
repository of skill sets
that exist.
Because we don't always need to
go outside where we could have
someone who's already
an expert, but how
do you discover that person?
Is that what you are
kind of getting at?
Well actually
it was slightly--
it was kind of like that.
And I'm fairly new
to knowledge graphs,
but the additional piece of
information I was thinking of
is the relationship stuff.
So person X has skill
Y or users tool X
and speaks to person Z.
So now who uses tool E?
So now you've got these
connections between individuals
as opposed to just dry data
of person X knows thing Y.
Yeah.
No, that makes complete sense.
But now doing an
emotion check, that
feels a little weird
without consent though.
I don't think I would
do it without consent.
But also, I think the
schema that you were just
talking about--
because now we're
kind of getting into
the nitty-gritty
of the different types of graph
databases, the Triplestore
versus an RDF.
And I would probably have the
person attributes on the person
node, but then have an
edge connecting to a tool
that they use.
But yeah, that type
of thing would--
yeah, with their consent, I
think that would be great.
If we had some sort of
registry that voluntarily--
but of course, now I'm also
doing the what's in it for me?
Don't we do anyway
with LinkedIn?
[LAUGHS]
Well, yeah.
We do have that
in LinkedIn, but I
don't know how open the API is.
I don't know what sorts
of access there would be.
But also, I'm just
thinking what's in it
for me scenario, the walk away.
Not Regis, but what's
in it for the people who
would voluntarily provide
their information.
That would have to
be substantiated.
And I'm not sure
if a conversation
would be sufficient of
a threshold to establish
an edge connecting to nodes.
But I think there's
definitely something there.
So the kind of
thing I'm thinking
is often when you reach out,
you say, OK, who knows R?
That's one question.
But then it's almost the
people off the fringes of that
who are kind of these people
know people who know R.
And so you can then say,
let's connect people together
who either are in the same
department or can find
other folks, kind of on
that loose connection sense.
Yeah.
No, no, it makes perfect sense.
[INAUDIBLE] but--
No, no, no, it
makes perfect sense.
I'm actually involved
in a big project
that I can't comment
on right now,
but I'm super excited about it.
And the only reason why I'm
involved in this project
is because somebody who's
not a data scientist
knew me and the stuff
that I worked on
and they saw someone
else struggling.
And they were like,
maybe Regis can help.
And then--
Maybe I'm biased
because I'm thinking
everyone comes through me.
Mike's the R guy, so
everything funnels in.
Whereas if we
said, look, there's
50, 100 people out
there who knew R
well enough better than
me that we can link you
guys up with someone
in your neighborhood
who knows that skill.
Well, see, I think
that's one use that you
can have of a team or
whatever type of Slack
or some sort of organization.
One thing I have
in the Microsoft
Teams for the group
that I have is
a channel for debugging
and collaboration.
The collaboration doesn't
really get used as much,
but the debugging one does.
And then also the
group that I was
in the R&amp;D side
of the company, we
started using Jira to receive
requests because we basically
became not just full stack data
scientists but full service
data scientists so going
all the way from the DevOps
end of the spectrum to
explanation, presentations
of really complex topics to
non-computational people.
And not just Shiny apps
or Markdown documents
or Python notebooks,
but actual presentations
and everything in between.
So yeah, it sounds like
you're going on a similar path
to what I did before.
And it's not scalable,
it's not sustainable.
But if there is
already momentum,
I don't honestly fully
know how to control that.
If anyone else knows,
please say it in the chat.
I don't know how.
Because if everyone
thinks you're the wizard--
and that's the challenge.
This is one of the reasons why
I have the community together
because none--
I'm not going to
say Muggles, even
though my wife is a
Potter head and this
looks like a Harry Potter--
but the uninitiated
sometimes think
that all magics are equal.
And that's for the
non-computational people.
And then for the
computational people,
if everyone else
is like, oh, you're
the person who's
standing out therefore
I will ask you for everything.
Both happened to me in
the small group of people
that I was on in
the early years.
Well, I guess one thing is if
you have a system like Jira--
and I see Jeff like Jira too--
if you have a system
like Jira, you
can kind of force an activation
energy to your own benefit.
Because if other people
have to jump through a hoop,
they may say, the
hoop isn't worth it.
If it's really burning,
then those that get through
give you an opportunity
to contribute
more to the institution
that you're a part of.
Can I have Eric ask another
question that's kind of related
to this topic too?
Eric, do you want to jump
in on the pipeline question?
Absolutely.
First Tron reference in
the Data Science Hangout,
my life's complete.
So nailed it, Regis.
So as someone who
can fully appreciate
making you might say sometimes
overengineered pipelines
or certain operations,
I really like what
you've been talking about here.
But first, are you responsible
for all of this solo?
And are you getting help
to build all this either
from IT groups or
others that are
enthusiastic about
community building you're
doing a Regeneron?
And I guess my
related question is,
is this part of your
recognized kind of role
at the company at Regeneron?
And is that being recognized,
do you think, to your liking?
That's a lot of
different questions.
Yeah, I went a lot there.
So I was getting help on the
other side of the company when
I was-- because there's multiple
pieces also of the effort.
There's the platform
and supporting
the platform in terms of
DevOps, supporting the platform
in terms of the users
that are data scientists,
supporting the platform
in terms of users
that are non-data scientists.
And then there is also the
recognition from above.
Different parts of
different companies
may recognize
things differently.
I am on the side
of the company that
understands the challenges
associated with it.
And I got a thumbs up
from the leadership
when I posted this
thing on my LinkedIn.
So that's great.
Like a literal
clicked thumbs up.
I'm not anymore responsible for
implementing at a DevOps level
and supporting fellow data
scientists in my current role.
So it's much more scalable.
And basically, I
have a cheat code--
I'm not a gamer, but I
know that's a phrase--
in the wiki.
Because basically, I
mean, the rule, right?
It's a soft rule but
it's kind of true.
When you're programming,
if you do something twice,
you might want to make
a function for it.
If you do it 10
times, you definitely
make a function for it
because now you fool me
10 times if you don't do it.
So basically, I just made
a function in Confluence.
Not a literal function,
but it is a life function.
And I'm able to copy and paste,
and it is relatively scalable
because I customize things so
that it can be done repeatedly.
But we had a team that
was supporting it.
And I was able to
hire people under me
when I was on the other
side of the company
when I had a broader
set of responsibilities.
But now I don't have a
team right now under me,
but we're getting
things set up again
to be kind of similar to the
other side of the company.
But the responsibilities
are a bit different.
So that's in terms
of the environment.
The ecosystem is
relatively scalable,
and the leadership
is aware of it
and likes the fact that
I'm able to connect
the dots with my colleagues
around the company
because it helps others.
But also, it helps
us because if we
can learn about efforts that
are being done elsewhere,
we can avoid
reinventing the wheel.
And we can save time, and we
can achieve more effective cost
avoidance.
So there is backing
from the leadership
in this iteration of
the responsibilities
that I maintain.
OK.
I have a question
to add on to that.
For people who
are starting to be
this person within
their organization,
how can they start to show
more of the value OF community
and elevate more of those
examples of connecting people
across an organization?
So I mean, since
my memories begin,
so I think six years
old or something,
it's always been the case.
And I'm glad that so
many people are still
on the call and
paying attention.
I'm always working
on editing and--
but this is also our community,
so it's easier to understand.
But since as long
as I can remember,
I've been familiar
with people's eyes
glazing over when
I explain things.
And adults, people
like 10 times my age
when I was a little kid all
the way up until now, that is--
I don't think it's
going to go away.
I mean, maybe if ChatGPT
becomes even better
and then we become
obsolete, OK, maybe.
But there's so many
different ways.
I don't think that's
going to go away.
I think the way to
prove the contribution,
the benefit of a community is--
I used the word stuck
and the other word
unstuck because that's really
the only thing the business,
any business, any
organization that's not
even a business cares about.
There's a bunch of stuff that
the organization has to do.
There are obstacles in
the way, they are stuck.
How do they get unstuck?
That's all data
science is for, really.
Well, you could probably
do it for exploration
and a bunch of other stuff.
But you can argue
that maybe that's also
for going from stuck to unstuck.
But the non-computational
people who
have the power to bestow upon
you promotions and more money
or whatever you value, more
influence over the company
to make other
decisions, they really
care about what is the
value of the institution.
If it's a business,
business value, going from
stuck to unstuck.
If you can show to--
I forgot who was asking the
thing earlier about a graph
database.
It doesn't necessarily
need to be instantiated
in a graph database.
But if you can show how the
existence of that community
propagates through
the network that
exists in the institution
to such an extent
that something goes
from stuck to unstuck
and you can mark that,
you can measure it,
then you can say this only
happened because of me.
I mean, there are other
types of organizations
which also should exist too.
But sometimes, they're
based on interest.
But interest is a lot
more difficult to prove
the benefit of than, for
lack of a better word,
pain-focused groups.
Like if you're a
community that's
gathered around pulling thorns
out of your colleagues arms,
then you can be like,
we pulled 15 thorns out
or we taught another group
how to pull 100 thorns out
because we were
forced multipliers.
That, I think, is
the way to prove
the impact of the community.
I'm not 100% sure
it's going to work
because they're still
going to be people
with eyes getting glazed over.
But if you say, what do
you hate about your job,
you person with
power that I need
to prove the use of
this community of to?
And then if you understand that
or maybe don't even ask them,
but you may know because they're
probably high enough profile
people at your institution that
you know what their values are
likely to be, if you
can think about how
the efforts that you're doing
propagate to the reduction
of pain points for those people
and enables them to go from
stuck to unstuck, then
collect those things.
And do like what I did
with the showcasing.
You could show like, hey,
people in this organization
did this, this,
this, and this, then
I think that could be
a way to prove impact.
Thank you for that.
Pankti, I realize we were
asking the same question
I think at the same time.
So I wanted to
make sure that you
didn't have any follow up that
you wanted to add in there too.
PANKTI SHAH: No, it's
a great question.
And I think-- first of all, I'm
really enjoying this discussion
because I'm doing something or
starting something very similar
in my organization.
And one of the things--
I am kind of
concerned of upcoming.
Like although I'm
really excited about it,
I don't know we
talked about a lot
of value of having a community.
But ultimately, I think
at least the company
I work for, it is
extremely result-driven
and for the right means.
People have communicating
this complexity
to potentially management
that's not really as involved
and understands the data
science or the value as much.
It feels more proving at
times at the starting point
like why this adds value.
And yeah, there is certainly
a lot of opportunities
that people can talk
about in showcase.
But ultimately,
that also means you
got more new opportunities
that have been found,
which is great.
But then it comes to, who
takes on those responsible?
Do we have enough
bandwidth to take those on?
And at the same time, how
do we kind of showcase
this community is
actually working?
It's worth people's hour
whether it's a month
or by weekly to show up to.
And I feel like
sometimes it could
be difficult to communicate that
in more guest to a management
because I understand that.
But I think I was just
wondering if there
are specific metrics
that people use
or words that kind of really
we can use to evaluate
whether it's success or not.
Because after, let's say, 6 to
8 months, should you keep going?
Yeah, maybe same people
are showing up, but like--
I don't know if you had
any additional insight.
Like I know you
talked a lot about it.
Maybe the world is different.
And maybe you're going
to feel differently
from how I felt.
But it starts off
being awesome because
as a people person--
only in contexts where
people are being nice.
I'm not a people person
where people are not nice.
But when you're in the
beginning and you're
starting a community
and everyone's happy
and that's wonderful.
But yeah, if you
end up eight months
and you're doing the same
thing and the leadership hasn't
recognized it, that
can not feel great.
It really stinks.
So I think from the
get go, you should
be thinking about how to
indicate to the leadership.
Actually, Pankti,
can you comment
on what you're hoping, though?
Because I want to kind of
respond to what you're saying.
But the same way that--
this is a roundabout
thing, but I
don't know if people have seen
in the news how Bing's chat
bot is starting to get passive
aggressive with people.
It's kind of getting
angry with people
because it's simulating human
thought and human emotion
to some degree.
And in my opinion, and also
I'm in a pharmaceutical company
which operates because
we know that people
have things in common, we
have standard hardware.
And so if you have standard
hardware, you can fix things.
But also, standard hardware
can break for the same reason.
But I accepted a long
time ago that I am kind of
like a biological robot.
And a lot of us are.
And I apply to
myself and to others
the same type of approach--
it doesn't always apply,
sometimes it needs
tweaking and stuff--
that I do to actual data
sets and decisions that
need to be made there.
So you need to think about
data-driven decision-making.
If you want the leadership to
make decision X in response
to your action Y, what is
the causal relationship
that will achieve that?
What are you hoping
will happen, Pankti.
PANKTI SHAH: I'm honestly
hoping at this point
that we actually
go to a place where
we are more driven by data,
especially in a scientific
like-- we obviously know people
look at data to make decisions,
but not to the extent
that it could be.
That's like a simple
win right there.
But you can--
So you want people
to-- go ahead, sorry.
PANKTI SHAH: And
then the second part
is, we have so much
data available,
but we almost feel like
we're under utilizing it.
That's why hence we
started this team
where we can start using it.
But in the team,
we have folks of
different various backgrounds.
But even getting like--
there is ideas, but
there is like there's
too much, at the same
time, there's not enough.
So it's like, how do you
even take what is important,
showcase events
right away to show
that, hey, this is important.
We should show leadership it
or a management thing like,
this is important.
We need more resources
because ultimately, that's
where it's going
to come down to.
And what we're doing,
how we're leveraging data
or how we're utilizing
it, kind of showcase that.
And I'm hoping that through
the sort of community,
we engage on more
of the discussion
because I know what I know or
the team knows what we know.
We don't know what the
opportunities are out there.
We don't know every
aspect of the business.
To me, to our team,
that would be the win.
But I guess it's tough
to showcase that.
It feels like it's
tough to showcase that.
So I still feel though that
there's two kinds of scenarios
that you're talking about.
One, are you preaching
to the choir or are you
preaching to the preacher?
Because it sounds
like you've got
three KPIs that are measurable,
like Key Performance
Indicators.
One is you want
to use data more.
The other is you want
to use more data.
And then the other is want
to use data more effectively.
So those are potentially
measurable outcomes
that you can determine if you
have achieved from the outset.
And then you can work
backwards to see how
you would get to that point.
And it feels like
there's probably
an emotional connection if
people are content to just say,
well, I already know X,
Y, Z domain, so I don't
need to use any other data.
That is an important
hump to get over
and perhaps
demonstrating to some
of the decision makers that
are above the groups that--
I mean, unless
it's not this case.
I don't know what
company you're at.
But if they're above the people
who are the choir already
that are already familiar
with the advantages
of data-driven decision
making and focusing
truly on the data
rather than opinions
and anecdotal evidence, figuring
out how to achieve those three
KPIs that you said.
And the simplest one might
be just use more data.
No, sorry.
Use data more.
Use more data comes
with it the challenges
of trying to identify
how to extract that data
and get it in the right format.
And you've maybe seen
in a lot of articles
that talk about a big part of
the data scientist job, 80%
of that is getting data ready.
And then 20% is actually
doing the data science.
But if you want to
start somewhere,
I think it may make sense to
try to use data more rather
than use more data.
And then use data
more effectively,
that sounds like an
optimization aspect.
But if you just say use data
more as your initial step,
then you can say, OK, this is--
you could try to
identify pain points.
I'm just trying to
think through here,
almost like consulting here.
But because I think the other
two are higher hanging fruit.
The lowest hanging
maybe is use data more.
And of use data more,
which is a project
that if you use the data
that you already have you
might be able to say
more incontrovertibly,
this is the decision
that you should make?
Which option would
be best for going
from stuck to unstuck most
easily in that easiest
to obtain KPI?
PANKTI SHAH: No, that's a really
good analogy and a really good
way to navigate this.
Now, thanks for your insight.
I really like that.
Definitely going to
use this approach.
Sweet.
Thank you.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I also
wanted to add in here
that I know we're getting
to the top of the hour,
but Marlene and
Chris and I we're
going to stay on after to
talk about just like starting
a community from scratch.
And it's super informal.
Of course, hangouts are
informal in general.
But we're just going to stay
on and chat a little bit
about that, especially when
you have people who might not
be as technical to begin with.
We were talking about just
like starting from scratch.
So if anybody wants to stay
on and just chat with us,
we'll be there.
But Regis, just
one other question.
Libby, sorry, I realized I
missed your question earlier.
Do you want to jump in, Libby?
Sure.
I have no idea what I asked.
It was about if you
could improve or solve--
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
If you could improve or solve
one thing about your industry,
what would it be?
Because mine is
onboarding, which
you then immediately talked
about and I was like,
huh, maybe his onboarding too.
I would love to be able
to give you a quick answer,
but there's only 2
minutes and I don't fully
know because there's five chunks
of the company that I'm in.
And I'm getting a stronger
and stronger hunch
that each chunk is basically
a different company
because this side of--
I haven't been here
nine months yet,
but it's like a completely
different company
from the other side.
But it actually may
fit into the three KPIs
that I was talking about.
I think one is be
more comfortable with
data-driven decision-making.
That's a challenge currently
because there's a lot of--
I don't know if you could
tell from the slight tinge
in my voice--
the feeling of like,
well, I know what I mean,
so that's enough.
And it would be
great if I knew how
to improve on how to communicate
to people such that they're
emotionally OK with saying, oh,
maybe I should look at the data
instead of trusting my gut.
I mean, people
should trust their--
trusting one's gut is
important, but your gut
is informed by common sense.
And common sense is common to
a subset of whatever your world
line is that led you
to that Tron point.
But you have to factor in
the entire 3D chess area of--
like you have to
factor in everybody
or as many perspectives
as possible.
And so data-driven
decision-making
enables the abstraction to a
broader set of perspectives.
And that's hard.
If I could figure out how
to do that, get over--
I see it's an emotional
hump for other people.
And I wish I could
improve on that.
And maybe it's also applicable
to the other side too.
But it's people and their
comfort with things.
That sounds great.
Sounds like a little bit less
ego for everybody, right?
I think ego is a good
way of saying that.
Maybe that's inflammatory,
but being more humble
and realizing that there's
a whole lot more going on
that you don't know that
you could know, right?
REGIS JAMES: Yes.
Love it.
Emotion is more ambiguous,
but ego is more accurate.
Thank you, Regis.
Regis, are you running
to a meeting right now?
I am not.
I have a thing in a
little bit, though.
OK.
Can I have Kaitlin
ask one last question
that I see was in the chat?
Sure.
I'll jump in.
Hi, Regis.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Hey, Kaitlin.
This has been a
really interesting chat,
but you mentioned earlier
that both your parents are
guidance counselors and your
fascination in humans, clearly,
and obviously, data science.
I was just wondering
if you've ever
done any projects on the mental
health side with data science
or if you have any interest to.
I have not.
But now thinking about it
though, one thing I don't like
is working in
areas of ambiguity.
And I think mental health
has a lot of ambiguity.
But also, it really
needs a lot of attention.
I think I would be
conflicted, but the necessity
of contributions in that domain
would help me overcome that.
I haven't been involved
and those types of things,
but yeah, it's definitely--
I mean, talk to anyone
who's gotten a PhD
and you will see a little bit
of darkness behind their eyes.
It beats you a lot.
I would say 9 out
of 10 people who've
gone through that probably have
some mental health things that
need to be addressed.
But it would be difficult to get
a clean data set off of that.
I know that's not what
you're asking me about,
but my brain automatically
goes to implementation,
how would that work?
But without a doubt,
that's something
that needs assistance.
And I probably would
be interested in that.
I'm not commenting
on whether or not
my institution is involved
in that kind of thing.
But I would be--
I don't know-- like--
I might be interested if
people wanted to collaborate
like offline or something.
Yeah.
There's this huge psychiatric
publicly-available data set.
It's like 20,000 participants,
half has mental illnesses,
half don't.
So when you're talking about
being stuck and unstuck,
I'm like relating
that to humans.
And those who get
mental illnesses
are kind of in that stuck zone.
And we can use data
science to overcome that.
But yeah, if you're
interested, I
can send you a message to
where that data set is.
Yeah.
That would be awesome.
I mean, do you know if there's
sequencing or expression
data, genome data that's
associated with it?
Not associated to that, no.
I wish.
I wish, but no.
OK.
Well, what's-- I mean, I don't
know what types of applications
that are for it.
The reason I ask is
because in grad school,
basically like the seminal
paper that I published
was about integrating genotype
and phenotype information
in an effort to identify what
the most likely causal variant
is of the patient's disease
that was diagnosed or suspected
by clinical geneticist.
So I'm just wondering about
the potential to integrate
and then the methods
of assaying it.
Because it needs
to be repeatable,
because if it's not,
then you can't really
trust the data if it's measured
inconsistently across the set.
So yeah, I'm just wondering
what the applications
of that type of thing are.
Yeah.
Again, that data
set there's lots
about childhood information,
demographics, stuff like that.
And I feel like classically, a
lot of psychological problems
are actually-- it's
not much genetics.
That's what I learned
in university anyway.
I'm a psych major.
I think the most like
genetically passed
on mental illness
would be schizophrenia,
and that's only
like 20 something.
I don't know.
I've been working with
this data set for a while,
and I have so many ideas
but yeah, thank you.
So this is the thing, like
it's the nature/nurture combo.
And the nature, I
think, is maybe easier,
even though it's
extremely complex
than the nurture aspect.
And if the cause is
different or varies
a lot because you have to
look at the world line--
I've said it like five
times now, but it is.
That's what you're
talking about, right?
If it's not genetic, then
it's because whatever happened
to them when they
went over the speed
bump 15 light squares ago.
So I don't know how you would--
it needs to be normalized.
But how can you normalize
something that is not
consistent across the data set?
That's a real challenge.
Or you could make
inferences that
are at a really broad level.
But then would that be
sufficient to suggest actions?
I don't know.
I see Jared asked Kaitlin
if you could share that link
to the data in the chat.
Yeah.
I'll find it real quick.
OK.
Awesome.
Just want to say
thank you, everybody,
for all the great questions.
And thank you so much,
Regis, for joining us
today and sharing all
your experience as well.
I think you gave me a
LinkedIn as the best place
to follow up with you.
Is that best?
Yeah.
I can put it in the chat too.
My LinkedIn is--
Just got it.
Right ahead of you.
Also I have a YouTube lets
you get your own at, A-T--
like the @ sign.
So I was like, I wonder if
data driven decision making
is available.
And it is.
I mean, it's a lot
of letters, but
like youtube.com/@dat
adrivendecisionmaking I own,
which is kind of cool.
Awesome.
Thank you so much, Regis.
Thank you, all.
Thank you.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Have a
great rest of the day.
Bye, everybody.